[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 11 avril bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal préparé par la
rédaction de tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de cette édition et réfléchir à
l'agriculture de demain c'était au
programme des rencontres de la plaine de
versailles elle se tenait hier au
château de thoiry ce rendez vous est un
temps des changes entre élus
associations agriculteurs et habitants
le thème cette année est l'urgence
climatique et la biodiversité
vd comme fête ses cinq ans pour
l'occasion l'institut installé à
versailles-satory organisé une journée
portes ouvertes qui devait être clôturée
par le ministre de l'ecologie françois
de rugy un travail d'innovation de
recherche et d'expérimentations sur les
mobilités durables notamment sur le
véhicule autonome et depuis 1996 pour un
sourire d'enfant aide les jeunes
victimes d' extrême provoque pauvreté au
cambodge ong a été cofondée par
marie-france des pallières qui a entamé
un tour d'europe pour raconter son
histoire ce soir elle est de passage à
buc avec celle à david rouge qui a été
accompagnée par l'association
ils sont à nos invités sur ce plateau
aussi à tout à l'heure de membres du
comité d'organisation de la nuit du
handicap à versailles l'événement 1
revient pour une deuxième édition ce
sera le 15 juin
elle nous débutons donc par une page
agriculture une grande soirée était
organisée ce mercredi à thoiry des élus
des associations ainsi que des acteurs
agricoles se sont réunis pour réaliser
un bilan de la plaine de versailles et
imaginer l agriculture de demain est le
reportage de michael et les minéraux les
acteurs du monde agricole yvelinois ont
pris la parole ce mercredi 10 avril au
château de thoiry une centaine de
personnalités de la plaine de versets
sont venus faire un état des lieux de
leur territoire à travers des
conférences
l'objectif était de faire le bilan de ce
qui a été fait depuis dix ans et se
donner des perspectives pour les
prochaines années
l'avenir il est passionnant et il
demande beaucoup d'intelligence
collective
il est passionnant parce que les défis
environnementaux ils ne sont pas l'autre
bout de la planète ils sont aussi à côté
de chez nous dans la salle des élus de
27 communes de la plaine de versailles
parmi eux des hommes politiques de saint
quentin en yvelines un territoire
composé à 20 % de terres agricoles qui
compte devenir acteurs de l'agriculture
de demain saint quentin en yvelines peut
intervenir par exemple dans le cadre de
l'accompagnement pour des nouvelles
installations pour des conversion vers
l'agriculture biologique
elle peut aussi intervenir pour
favoriser le développement de points de
vente pour les circuits courts pour une
plus grande proximité entre les
producteurs et les consommateurs
elle peut aussi intervenir en
coordination avec les communes que c'est
pas sa compétence directe sur
l'alimentation locale au niveau de la
restauration collective des politiques
mais également des particuliers sont
venus à thoiry c'est le cas du fondateur
de la biscuiterie les deux gourmands
installé à crépir depuis 2012 et qui
compte aujourd'hui plus de 400 points de
vente en local
à terme j'ai vraiment la sensation qu'on
est en train de créer un endroit un lieu
un territoire qui sera à terme
exemplaire
j'en suis persuadé sur le mieux produire
et le mieux consommer le prochain bilan
de l'agriculture en plaine de versailles
est programmée pour l'année prochaine
les communes de moins de 2000 habitants
davantage aider dans leur projet le
département va créer un contrat rural
yvelinois huit de ces documents ont été
signés hier au siège de la collectivité
à versailles le dispositif vient
compléter le contrat rural actuel qui
permet aux communes de faire financer
par la région et le département
une partie de leurs projets en matière
d'équipement et des espaces publics et
les villages qui avait tout de même un
reste à charge de 30% le contrat rural
yvelinois permet une augmentation et du
plafond de la subvention départementale
à hauteur de 230 mille euros et donc un
reste à charge réduits pour les communes
les propos sont recueillis par nicolas
dandrès ça participe à la qualité de vie
chinoise quand vous dites on habite
le département des yvelines vous voyez
en ile de france les gens vous enviez
parce que quand on traverse ce
département ses forêts ses chants ses
petites communes avec ses bâtiments
refait ses belles routes
ces luminaires de qualité tout ça
participe à la qualité de vie noise et
encore une fois c'est l'essence même des
yvelines la signature de ce contrat
rural c'est l'essentiel pour réhabiliter
notre nouvelle mairie à peu près 450
mille euros pour la réhabilitation et
donc avec ces deux chèques de 140 8000
euros de valérie pécresse et celui de
monsieur bédié 111 milles euros
je pense qu'on va pouvoir faire pas
s'autofinancer
pour les reste et ce dispositif du
contrat rural yvelinois sera créée
officiellement lors d'un vote en
assemblée départementale et vidé comme à
5 ans l'institut de recherche installé à
versailles fête cet anniversaire en
regardant vers l'avenir 200 employés
réfléchissent à une mobilité du futur
autour de véhicules électriques et
autonome une journée portes ouvertes
était proposée ce jeudi sur place
patrick jacques de dixmude le récit de
mélanie poker faire des milliers de
kilomètres sans s'arrêter avait des
comme on pense à la route de demain pour
les véhicules électriques etc cette
piste de recharge grâce à des bobines
communicants entre la voiture et la
route des bodys la piste et d'y
augmenter sa autonomie dans la ville
c'est la technologie est le plus
intéressant encore parce qu' on a des
endroits où les véhicules roulent moins
vite dans que par exemple des vents
défaut rouge
il s'arrête complètement il ya ces
moments là si la piste des vents de faux
le faut il va séchage et plus cette
piste est l'un des sujets de recherche
de l'institut basé à versailles vd comme
célèbre cette année ses cinq ans n'avait
autonome création de start up aux études
des flux de mobilité la toute première
nouveauté c'est le bâtiment au sein
duquel nous sommes celles au mobile app
puisque nous avons fédéré toutes nos
équipes dans un seul bâtiment c'est
un emplacement dans lequel nous étudions
la mobilité du futur et nous y menons
des activités qui concerne à la fois
l'électrification du véhicule nous y
travaillons également sur tout ce qui
est technologique lié à la perception à
la localisation du véhicule autonome
ainsi que les facteurs humains et vd
comme aujourd'hui ce sont 200 employés
des chercheurs pour plus de la moitié
d'un statut signe aussi des partenariats
le groupe ratp est devenu aujourd'hui
l'un des nouveaux membres pour réfléchir
à des transports publics autonomes un
tour d'europe à travers la suisse le
luxembourg la belgique et la france il a
été entamée depuis début mars par l'omg
pour un sourire d'enfant cette
initiative passe ce soir par le théâtre
des arcades de buc et est mené par mes
deux invités et qui sont en plateau
marie-france despallières est celle à
david ou chaumont soir à vous deux
sports alors marie-france des pallières
vous avez fondé en 1996 cette
association pse pour un sourire d'enfant
avec votre mari christian aujourd'hui
décédé et c'est là david vous avez été
accompagné par pse vous êtes aujourd'hui
professeur de français à phnom penh la
capitale du cambodge on va parler bien
sûr votre histoire dans un instant cette
association je précise qu'elle aide les
enfants victimes de l'extrême pauvreté
au cambodge
marie-france des pallières une première
question pourquoi faire ce tour d'europe
faire sauter des robes pour faire
connaître ce qui se passe au cambodge
pour faire connaître les difficultés
quand certaines familles certains
enfants
difficultés graves et pour essayer de
pour dire d'abord que l'on peut faire
quelque chose et que pour essayer
d'avoir des personnes qui nouvelles
personnes qui nous aident non sur la
forme de ces soirées 16 027 façon donc
une projection d'un film au cambodge de
la misère à un métier qui est suivi de
votre témoignage c'est là david
pourquoi accepter de faire ce tour
d'europe avec marie-france des pallières
temps donc en fait c'est mamie m'a
choisie parce que je travaille
maintenant à l'écho du si le cinéma donc
que je connaisse la technique pour pour
montrer pour projeter le film est en
fait je parle français aussi donc c'est
pour ça m'a amené à décider de choisir
pour la tournée annuelle des mets dix
neuf dont parle de votre histoire dans
un instant alors une aventure humaine où
on ne pense on imagine forcément
incroyable avec plus de vingt ans au
sein de cette ong
j'aimerais qu'on revienne ou tout début
fin 1995 lorsque vous vous rendez au
cambodge avec votre mari christian
qu'est-ce que vous constaté sur place
en fait on travaillait depuis deux ans
dans notre association qui s'appelle
aussi par qui existe toujours et envoyer
des enfants dans les rues qui étaient
dans des dispositions épouvantable qui
ramasser des ordures les plastiques etc
pour qu'ils revendaient pour survivre et
on n'avait pas le temps pendant ces deux
années là on n'avait pas le temps de
faire quoi que ce soit et quand on a eu
terminé cette première mission
on est allé les voir on leur a demandé
si ce qu'on pouvait faire pour eux ils
nous emmenaient sur la décharge et là
c'était insupportable mais courant dans
le courant de l'année 1996 vous fondez
donc cette ong depuis onze mille enfants
ont pu être aidés grâce à celle-ci de
quelle manière quels sont les types
d'actions que vous avez pu mettre en
place donc en bonne et au départ on leur
a commandé et on leur a demandé ce dont
ils avaient besoin
ils nous ont demandés un repas par jour
est allé à l'école donc voilà on a
commencé comme ça on les a nourris
on les a emmenés on les a scolarisée en
donnant une du riz en compensation parce
que les familles n'avaient pas la
possibilité de laisser partir autrement
et voilà petit à petit on a eu beaucoup
d'amis qui sont mis à côté de nous et
qui ont permis que on a actuellement
6500 plus de 6500 enfants dans les
programmes et 4500 qui ont déjà un
travail qui sont diplômés et qui en a
aussi une formation professionnelle
alors parmi ses enfants il ya eu celle à
david que vous croisez à l'âge de 7 ans
vous êtes le dernier d'une fratrie de
six enfants vos journées commencent à 4
heures du matin pour cueillir des
liserons d'eau revendus par votre mère
il ya aussi une marche quotidienne de 40
minutes à l'époque pour vous rendre à
l'école publique et vont ramasser
marie france n'est pas leur parler de ce
ramassage des plastiques plastiques et
papiers aussi afin de pouvoir les vendre
et aider votre mère en quoi ça changer
votre vie de croiser la route de
marie-france des pallières donc en fait
quand je peux rentrer à personne ne
connaît à vie a changé beaucoup
j'appelle à l'école je peux continuer
mes études au département de
francophones à phnom penh au cambodge
et oui et finalement j'ai commandé je
peux avoir un bon travail a payé et je
suis maintenant conseiller d'éducation
et admiratif à l'école l'audiovisuel et
de pc si vous êtes très passionné par le
cinéma
oui c'est ça oui et donc vous êtes
aujourd'hui professeur de français à
phnom penh
est-ce que vous vous sentez redevable de
ce qu'a apporté vous a apporté
l'association est et à votre tour le
transmettre aux jeunes cambodgiens
voilà exactement parce que personne m'a
donné beaucoup la chance donc c'est pour
ça
j'aimerais bien de donner un coup de
main pour pc lorsqu'il y en a beaucoup
d'enfants qui attend l'aide de paix
c'est pour ça j'aimerais bien que des
gens entrent avec le pc maintenant
justement ne faisait pas lieu
aujourd'hui sur place au cambodge il
reste beaucoup à faire encore beaucoup à
faire beaucoup à faire
parce que le kangoo tu développes très
vite mais ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens
de rentrer dans le développement
ils s'en sortent pas ils ont besoin d'un
coup de main pour démarrer et déjà
commencé envoyez-vous fameux permettre à
leurs enfants d'aller à l'école
et puis aussi en donne un coup de main
aux familles quand c'est nécessaire
parce que ces personnes si vous voulez
qu'ils n'ont pas l'occasion de ni
d'aller à l'école signé d'avoir deux
formations et c'est impossible d'en
sortir et du projet actuel menée par pse
quels sont ils
c'est de continuer c'est quand il y en a
encore beaucoup
comment se déroule ce tour d'europe il
est entamée depuis depuis mars
comment se déroule si elle est ce que
l'accueil est au rendez vous à chaque
fois tout à fait on a des salles très
sympathique et des gens qui sont très
doués qui comprennent la situation et
puis alors maintenant est-ce qu'ils
s'engagent tous je ne sais pas on n'a
pas encore les résultats m'enfin voilà
notre but c'est de faire connaître quand
même et de faire connaître un côté et
puis dire qu'on peut aider si vous avez
besoin de soutien
aujourd'hui absolument toujours autant
que autant qu'avant et on peut donner
bien sûr sur votre site internet qui
s'affiche rappelle que le tour d'europe
va passer également très prochainement
par bruxelles en belgique à part le
luxembourg est un point d'étape donc ce
soir à buc et l'himalaya les lilas fans
de 24 et 25 de mémoire 24 et 25 avril
nous dans toute la france et aussi dans
des pays francophones de l'europe point
d'étape ce soir donc au théâtre des arts
cas d'abus que c'est à partir de 20h15
merci marie france des pallières merci
c'est l'assassinât d'être passé sur ce
plateau je rappelle toutes les
informations sur le site à 2 cette ong
qui s'affiche le retour des beaux jours
vous donnent sans doute l' envie de
faire un petit ménage de printemps dans
vos armoires pour alléger votre
garde-robe le centre commercial espace
saint quentin propose en ce moment un
vide dressing solidaire il se tient sur
la place des pyramides jusqu'à samedi
vous pouviez y donner vos vêtements et
accessoires que vous ne portez plus ils
seront
ont revendu au sein d'une boutique
éphémère est les bénéfices réalisés vous
seront reversés en cartes-cadeaux les
pièces invendues elles seront remises à
l'association le relais coopératives
sociales engagées notamment dans le
recyclage des vêtements on reparle dans
un instant solidarité dans ce journal
juste avant ce reportage lycéens et
étudiants avaient rendez vous hier à
bois d'arcy pour tenter de trouver un
job d'été un forum était organisé par
yveline information jeunesse les jeunes
candidats avaient la possibilité de
rencontrer des recruteurs issus de
secteurs très variés or ils iront et
nicolas landry des rencontres entre des
employeurs et des jeunes organisé par le
réseau départemental information
jeunesse ce forum jobs d'été a réuni
près de 25 recruteurs dans la salle des
fêtes de bois d'arcy
c'est vrai que c'est un pas vers
l'autonomie c'est à dire leur première
expérience professionnelle que people va
qui peuvent valoriser sur leur cv
et puis pour certains c'est aussi un
financièrement pouvoir financer leur
permis pouvoir financer leurs vacances
d'autres projets ces postes saisonniers
sont accessibles dès l'âge de 16 ans ce
type de forum est toujours un rendez
vous très attendu par les jeunes
travailleurs le chercheur pour gagner
l'argent et les divertir j'ai quasiment
trois mois de vacances du faut savoir
dépasser arrêt à faire en fait dès cet
été je vais devenir majeur donc partir
en vacances sans ses parents il faut
automatiquement de l'argent différents
secteurs d'activité étaient représentées
parmi les recruteurs de la grande
distribution des enseignes de commerce
l'hôtellerie-restauration et la mairie
de bonnart si nous connaissons un poste
en voirie donc pour les services
techniques nous recherchons quatre
quatre jeunes pour le mois de juillet
quatre jeunes pour le mois d'août la
voirie c'est autant pour les filles que
pour les garçons il faut juste être
volontaire et courageuse prochain rendez
vous pour les jeunes à la recherche d'un
job d'été le 15 mai à chanteloup les
vignes
c'est un geste solidaire qui peut sauver
des vies le don du sang elancourt
accueille demain une collecte à l'hôtel
de ville les réserves sont faibles en ce
moment et des dons réguliers sont
nécessaires pour assurer assurer des
stocks de produits sanguins un million
de malades en bénéficient chaque année
en france est la collecte se tient de 9
heures à 14 heures et de 15 heures à 20
heures pour donner il faut être majeur
peser plus de 45 kg et être en bonne
santé
un événement qui revient
versailles la deuxième édition de la
nuit du handicap se tiendra le samedi et
15 juin c'est un événement national et
dans une vingtaine de villes en france
et donc à versailles ça se tiendra de le
15 juin de 17h à minuit à la rotonde
ce chiffre pour commencer 12 millions de
personnes qui sont concernées par le
handicap en france vont à 80% de manière
invisible on va présenter cet événement
avec mes deux invités avec qui m'ont
rejoint autour de cette table xavier de
senneville et françois pottier bonsoir à
vous deux bonsoir merci de votre
présence à voir vous êtes tous les deux
membres du comité d'organisation de
cette nuit du handicap à versailles une
première question quels sont les
objectifs de l'événement alors cette
nuit handicap qui aura lieu en fait de
14h à 23h
nous sommes beaucoup plus ambitieux 3
heures du matin voilà dans 23 secondes
trois heures avant donc à la rotonde 5
rue royale à versailles donc c'est avant
tout un événement festif pour créer la
rencontre un événement joyeux reda
rencontre entre les personnes porteuses
de handicap et les personnes valides
pour faire tomber des préjugés et puis
surtout pour pour s'amuser autour des
talents de chacun ça a changé
changer les regards c'est c'est l'un des
objectifs françois pottier oui c'est
changer de regard c'est apporter une
atmosphère sympathique et joyeuse
ouverte à tous puisque c'est gratuit
ouvert à tous comme je lé précisément
dit vous allez retrouver tout type de
handicap visible ou invisible et dans
une ambiance festive vous pourrez même
dîner sur place insisté un des one man
show des pièces de théâtre des concerts
des ateliers
voilà pourquoi il faut changer les
regards aujourd'hui quelles conséquences
filmant sa aujourd'hui parce que le
handicap est quelque chose qui peut
faire peur et hank et qu'il s'en doute
mal compris on sait bien que les
personnes en situation de handicap
vivent beaucoup de situations difficiles
et sans autre sans autre objectif on est
là pour les aider a décaré leurs talents
et montrer que
il n'y a pas de différence est que tout
un chacun on est capable de s'amuser et
d'avoir une rencontre on a compris le
côté festif qui est très important dans
cet événement alors une deuxième édition
après celle de l'an passé à verser
commence assez s'est déroulé ce que ça a
été une réussite
cette première édition oui c'était
effectivement une réussite à la fois
pour nous organisateurs on a vraiment
passé à de très bons moments et pour les
visiteurs également puisqu'ils sont
venus alors on fait très peu de
publicité sont venus en nombre dès la
première année
donc cette année nous avons anticipé
davantage et nous allons faire davantage
de promotion pour laquelle d'ailleurs
nous aurons appel à des bénévoles s'il
le souhaite et c'est une évidence de
leur proposer que cet événement
s'installe à versailles dans la durée
qu'il soir proposée chaque année alors
l'objectif est qu'ils s'installent
durablement effectivement donc à
versailles on a un peu plus un peu plus
de deux mois de l'événement à présent es
ce que vous avez déjà une idée du
programme de cette soirée
alors avant tout je souhaite par rapport
à votre question de tout à l'heure nous
cette organisation enfin cet événement
et sous le haut patronage de sophie
cluzel le ministre il y a donc une
communication qui est fait au niveau
national auprès des préfets auprès des
mères etc
puisque cette nuit n'en du cap se veut
être pérenne dans le temps et bien
bientôt lieu de la nuit de la musique
avec la nuit de la musique on parlera de
la ligne andy kapp parce que sa race
aura un rayonnement national et est
porteur de sens pour tous il s'installe
donc dans la durée on l'a bien compris
du coup sûr le programme est ce que vous
avez déjà une idée du programme 2019
alors le programme 2010 9 lui ai fait
deux dons de jeux pour les enfants pour
les adultes il y à des tables de ping
pong handisport il y à des spectacles et
one man show des danses des pièces de
théâtre enfin une foultitude
d'animations qui qui devrait plaire à
tous et que reste-t-il à faire pour
cette organisation justement beaucoup
c'est à dire là
le faire savoir on a un savoir faire
maintenant il faut le faire savoir nous
parliez du programme je peux déjà vous
dire que nous devrions avoir une
chanteuse émérite qui s'appelle angélina
tezanou qui s'est déjà produit devant le
pape jean paul ii il ya quelques années
comme une chanteuse aveugle africaine
qui a un talent fou pour faire bouger
tout le monde au bout de cinq minutes
elle ne voit rien mais elle entend tout
voilà nous aurons des également un one
man show avec bienvenue héros qui est
une personne aveugle mais qui racontent
tous les côté festif tout le côté
humoristique auxquels il est confronté
depuis qu'il est devenu aveugle voilà
peut-être aurons-nous un des meilleurs
si ce n'est le meilleur élève du mime
marceau qui nous vient d'allemagne qui
nous fera une présentation interactive
avec des sketches tout à fait
intéressant donc à un programme chargé
pour cette nuit du handicap est ce que
vous êtes à la recherche de bénévoles
justement pour que cette organisation se
passe au mieux de ces pays on est tous
bénévoles donc il faut encore plus de
bénévoles à la fois avant pour tracter
sur les marchés pour déposer des
affiches pour nous faire connaître par
tous les moyens possibles et puis
surtout le jour j puisque la dernière on
a accueilli environ 500 personnes là de
façon ambitieuse vont donc accueillir
deux fois plus donc imaginez toute
l'organisation que ça va demander et
surtout pendant on prend cette journée
qui dure quand même de 14h à 23h dont
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à faire dans
la joie et donc on appelle tous les
bénévoles qui voudront bien nous
rejoindre mais ce soit des techniciens
qui ont le sens du spectacle des
bénévoles pour la sécurité pour
l'accueil enfin vraiment tous les
talents sont sont accueillis avec
plaisir et pour plus d'information pour
rejoindre cette équipe d'organisation de
la nuit du handicap je vous invite à
vous rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas d'écran merci à xavier
de senneville françois pothier et c'est
là c'est sur ce plateau membre du comité
d'organisation de cette nuit du handicap
à versailles est la deuxième édition se
déroulera le samedi à 15 juin
à la retombée culture à présent le
festival rire soleil continue les
artistes parcours l'agglomération de
versailles grand parc pour faire sourire
les spectateurs ce samedi une nouvelle
date est organisée à bièvres et en
première partie des adolescents vont
assurer le spectacle mélanie poké
[Musique]
raymond devos tôt le texte dans
l'attitude et dans la pensée interprété
par cet adolescent de bièvre âgés de 11
à 14 ans à la création
marguerite shane artiste
pluridisciplinaire invité par le
festival continue à transmettre les
oeuvres de raymond devos parce que
c'était quelque chose qui lui tenait à
coeur et donc notamment pour les jeunes
générations
et deux
d'avoir un échange avec avec ces jeunes
à de pouvoir monter en quelques séances
un petit spectacle petite performance
autour de l'univers de raymond devos
le travail sur le texte mais aussi sur
le mouvement marguerite chahine a voulu
jouer sur les codes urbains du battle
hip hop
les apprentis comédiens ont travaillé
lors de quatre sessions pendant le cours
de théâtre en fait travailler en groupe
enfin c'est comme le théâtre un peu et
du coup c'est un peu de la danse tous
intéressants c'est l'occasion de passer
devant du monde et de bas a répété une
scène de théâtre
chen beaucoup d'émotion les gestes la
voix etc
je trouve ça super à raymond devos
continuera à planer sur cette soirée du
13 avril les jeunes laisseront leur
place à michael hirsh avec son spectacle
pourquoi pourquoi être comme tout le
monde
je veux dire il ya déjà plein de monde
comme tout le monde et puis vous
connaissiez sûrement les food truck
place aujourd'hui au wine trucks qu'il
s'agit d'un caviste ambulants qui permet
de découvrir des vins atypiques sur des
marchés ce nouveau concept vient de
s'implanter dans les yvelines
une découverte signé oridion ce tous les
samedis matin le camion de rachel prend
place sur le marché du chéné après une
expérience aux états unis c'était piqûre
yen a eu envie de réaliser un de ses
rêves comprendre comment on faisait du
bon vin elle décide alors de développer
les pépites de rachel un concept de
cavistes nouvelle génération l'idée
c'est vraiment d'aller d'aller vers le
client
plutôt que d'attendre de finalement
lorsqu'on fait son marché ont construit
son son son repas son dîner et il manque
le vin quand le vin vient à vous c'est
extraordinaire donc là on est sur le
marché le vin vient dans le truck dans
le petit camion et ça c'est extrêmement
sympathique
le concept de white rock n'est pas
encore très répandue notamment en ile de
france
quand elle n'est pas dans son camion sur
les marchés rachel se déplace dans tous
les terroirs afin de proposer à ses
clients des vins élevés en viticulture
raisonnée et des vins bio je choisis mes
vins en allant à la rencontre des
vignerons comprendre comment ils font
leur vin allez dans leurs vignes aller
dans leur cave dans leurs chais les
écouter raconter leur histoire pour que
moi je puisse aussi raconter cette
histoire à mes clients chaque samedi une
trentaine de vins est proposée à la
clientèle une sélection renouvelée
régulièrement les gammes de prix entre 8
et 22 euros la bouteille
déjà on a affaire à quelqu'un qui
connaît parfaitement les vins et qui les
aiment donc c'est important pour les
pour les vendre et puis du coup quand on
arrive avec une une idée précise de
davin pour un mais c'est beaucoup plus
facile à accorder chaque mois rachel
partage également ses coups de coeur sur
son site internet les pépites de rachel
un concept qu'elle souhaite développer
dans toute la france et à consommer bien
sûr avec modération c'est la fin de
cette édition replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 les idées de sorties du week-end à
retrouver dans un instant dans le 7-8
culture présentée par marylène iapichino
quant à moi je vous retrouve dès lundi
pour une nouvelle édition du 7 8 journal
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]